jurisdictions  yo we been living good  if you ain't busy i got a gig for you  real classic  all you gotta do is break into a  corporate zone and only  plan a party  fine teddy what's this itch see that  garage on the left  belongs to kandachi tip came in they've  got some special goods sitting in there  special for the sixth street gang  so what's on me to do you get in the  garage  and place this tracker under the truck  just just watch out for surveillance  cams  piece of cake you are making my career  right here v  the soldier of truth all right  teddy time to get to work just  you know do your ninja stuff and don't  get caught on camera  cameras love me not you i'll be in touch  is  [Music]  what  calm down where are you  gonna be a good day  what  framework it's gonna [ __ ] so hard on  those  [ __ ] they won't know what hit him  anyways  respect for running the tip top up  closing the contract  and releasing your eddies